alien covenant is directed by Ridley
Scott and is the sequel to Prometheus
but the prequel to alien and in this
film the crew of a ship called the
Covenant is heading to a planet to
hopefully colonize but when they find
out there's a much closer planet with
better vital signs they decide to go
there first and of course that was a bad
idea because there's some really
horrible there I know I'm
definitely in the minority when I say
that I love Prometheus the scientist
characters I could have done without
them but I found that to be a very smart
and risky sci fi movie it was risky
because a lot of people went in
expecting Xenomorphs and we didn't get
that and a lot of people complained that
there were no xenomorphs and so this
time around rather than continuing the
Prometheus storyline the way they had
initially thought they have decided to
mash up alien and Prometheus and here
these films converge we finally get some
answers about certain things that were
left hanging in prometheus but for the
most part this is a movie that has a
Prometheus esque feel there's even some
musical themes that are directly from
Prometheus but it's an alien movie from
the very beginning you can hear Jerry
Goldsmith's score done by a new person
this time around named Jed kurz L
because obviously Goldsmith has since
passed away but they are going for the
alien feel even the way the title comes
on the screen is flat-out alien and so
Ridley Scott is dealing with a lot of
cool things here and things that I get
really excited about because not only am
i a sucker for movies that involve
isolation in space or planets or aliens
or things like that
no one directs sci-fi like Ridley Scott
no one not only are all of his science
fiction films absurdly gorgeous they are
all very bold and they have a lot to say
it's not just about the alien creature
even the first alien which some could
just call a movie about a monster on a
ship had so many more themes just in its
art direction the production design the
pseudo sexual imagery everything about
that film is as close to perfect as
movies get and I could talk for days
about Blade Runner the things I didn't
like about it the things I loved about
it that's such a thought-provoking movie
and Prometheus as I said I found to be a
very smart movie here in Alien covenant
he once again has made a gorgeous film
and it's easy to say that
and kind of shrug it off but it's
important to realize how much work
really goes into making a film this
beautiful even though there's a lot of
CG a lot of stuff is in camera you can
tell because Scott is obsessed with
getting things in camera if you ever
watch the special features of Prometheus
you'd be blown away at just how much of
that movie was not green screen and here
once again this film is breathtaking
this is easily one of the most beautiful
looking films I've seen all year there
are shots that are still burned into my
subconscious and they're going to stay
there forever it is not a great thumb
though and I have problems with it and a
lot of it does have to do with tone
there is definitely a point in which
Prometheus converges with alien and it's
that point that feels off it's very
exciting and fun to watch and everything
looks amazing and all of the acting is
top-notch
but tonally there's a very dramatic
shift in the third act that while I was
excited for it and hoping for it and
looking forward to seeing it it just
didn't feel like it was the same movie
also covenant follows essentially the
same formula as alien and Prometheus
there are just different things and
really compelling ideas that are
sprinkled throughout all three of those
films basically all of them are about
some people in space who discover
something far away and go to explore it
some really bad happens and then
hits the fan and pretty much all
three of them Ridley Scott's films
follow that very similar formula but
gratefully some of the ideas present in
Prometheus are explored more in this
film there's a storyline that I will not
spoil because I honestly didn't know
about it going in and so I want you guys
to have that same experience but it
involves someone trying to persuade a
character into sharing their viewpoints
and I found it utterly fascinating
easily the most compelling part of the
film for me as I said I really
appreciated the acting but for myself
the standouts were surprisingly Danny
McBride he was great and Michael
Fassbender Michael Fassbender really
carries this movie in a lot of ways he
has a lot of work to do in this movie
and he owns every
second of screentime he's on and I
really can't wait for you guys to see
exactly what they do there are two
sequences in this movie that are so
white knuckled on the level of the
caesarian sequence and prometheus and
it's during those two sequences that I
realized that my mouth was slightly a
gape and I was just staring at the
screen and all what I was looking at and
a lot of that has to do with incredible
production design amazing direction the
score the editing the performance is the
CG all of it really comes together
really well in a few specific key
moments to really heighten the intensity
level and thank goodness is rated R
because there are some bloody sequences
that were highly satisfying so as I said
totally this movie had some
inconsistencies but since I was such a
big fan of Prometheus I liked a lot of
things they did in this film the acting
is top-notch
Catherine Watterson wasn't bad but I
really didn't have much interest in her
character I can see people watching this
and finding the characters rather
disposable another big issue that I have
is that you can pretty much always tell
when someone's about to bite the dust
they go that cliched horror route of
having someone go off for a smoke break
or go take a shower and it's just so
obvious that they're about to become the
prime target of the xenomorph and I
found that rather disappointing too so
tonally some of the script decisions and
that third act felt off to me but
overall I really enjoyed watching alien
covenant and I think it's probably the
third or fourth best alien film I'm
going to give a lien covenant of be guys
thank you so much as always for watching
please do check out my alien series I
have reviewed every film from the first
all the way to AVP to rec reom that was
fun I'm going to leave a playlist link
for that in the second here you guys can
check that out and special thanks to
Brandon and Ryan I met you guys the
screening tonight it was really cool
meeting you thank you so much for coming
up to me you guys are awesome thank you
very much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]